in manhattan talking to dr jonathan
height who's a professor at nyu and uh
i'm here for a bunch of reasons jonathan
is an extremely interesting researcher
i've been following his work on disgust
and political belief for
literally for decades he was one of the
first people who started to do serious
research on disgust which is its own
emotional system and therefore very much
worth attending to
but we also have some other
interests in common jonathan also
started this institute called the
heterodox academy which is attempting to
bring back a reasonable diversity of
views or what he regards as a reasonable
diversity of views to university faculty
and and campuses and discussions so
i first met
jonathan it's going to be just about 30
years ago
25 years ago that was in 2014 yeah 20
i'm sorry in 1994. oh it was in 1994
yeah yeah right right so yeah you came
to do a job talk at harvard to for an
assistant professorship position and i'd
been aware of your work on disgust then
and and agitated hard for them to hire
you because i thought it was of great
significance which turned out to be
exactly the case so what do you remember
about that
i remember i was so excited to have an
interview at harvard it was my only
interview if i didn't get that job i had
no job for the following year
and it was a very strange day in which i
didn't feel particularly welcome or
wanted and then i had my
session with you in which here was this
guy who was
had a he actually got a job at harvard
and he was studying jung which is like
almost taboo and he was talking about
dreams and creativity and so i just that
was the really bright that was the
bright memory of the day was our
hour-long conversation yeah well i was
also really interested at the time and
now in in the biological basis of
behavior right and so and and in the
in the relationship between fundamental
motivational systems and thought because
obviously
our thought is grounded in fundamental
motivational systems and your work on
disgust which maybe you can tell the
viewers a little bit about was really
interesting to me because it was an
emotional system that hadn't been
studied much i mean you were really one
of the pioneers in the in the
psychological study of disgust well the
way to explain it is that paul rosin my
advisor at pan is the pioneer in the
study of disgust and he'd studied it as
a food related emotion and he'd written
a bit about it being a moral emotion and
i was a graduate student at penn and i
was interested in morality and i was
reading the bible and i was reading
anthropological accounts of different
countries and different cultures and at
the time morality was all about
reasoning about harm rights and justice
so lawrence kohlberg was the leading
figure in the field
and because i was looking at morality
across cultures
and when you look across cultures it's
not just about fairness and harm and
rights it's about menstruation and food
taboos and skin lesions and it's very
physical and i was you know why why do
so many
societies why is it like the normal
default way of being is to somehow bring
the body into morality why is that
and so i just happened to be at penn
where the world's expert in disgust was
and i went to talk to him and that
started one of the best collaborations
of my life
and what it led to is is it broadening
of the of the moral domain basically
there's a sort of western uh secular
approach that you see in western
philosophers
either morality is about harm and
utilitarianism and it's minimize harm or
it's about rights and principles you
know emanuel kant
and
a much better way psychologically to
think about morality is virtue ethics
it's just a lot of stuff it's just we
have just a lot of stuff that we judge
on and this led me eventually to realize
that people on the left and people on
the right care about different stuff
everybody cares about harm and fairness
but the stuff about keeping you know
boundaries around the group build a wall
protect the group hold the group
together hate traders
you know everybody can do that but
right-wing morality builds on these
additional additional foundations of uh
these additional emotions and
foundations
so that work on disgust that i was just
beginning to talk about then when we
first met in 1994 led eventually to what
we now call moral foundations theory and
with might with about five or six um
colleagues if you go to yourmorals.org
uh you can take our test you can learn
all about it um but it led to the
perspective that ultimately was i think
the right perspective as the cultural
war was heating up and as left and right
were essentially becoming like different
countries different cultures
so so it's not obvious
on first consideration why disgust would
be a moral emotion so you know most of
the work that's done that's outside of
the discussed realm i would say
is predicated on the assumption that the
reason that conservatives in particular
but perhaps people who are more
authoritarian in general
draw boundaries around their territories
because they're afraid of the other but
that isn't really that isn't really how
it plays out as far as i can tell
because conservatives for example are
less neurotic than trait in the big five
trait sense than liberals although it's
a it's a minor difference but the
disgust issue seems to be particularly
relevant so so can you tell us a little
bit about why disgust per se
well first conservatives are a little
less neurotic but they also if you do
very low level perceptual experiment
just like a puff of white noise in the
ear people who react more strongly to
that to any sort of very low level
threat are more likely to vote
republican in this country so there you
know there are all these interesting
personality differences that lead to
different politics but as for why i
discussed um
so
i'm i'm a durkheimian i would say i love
the uh the sociologist emil durkheim
and i'm also i'm a social psychologist
so i'm always thinking not about people
as individual utility maximizers but
people as members of social groups
people who are
totally focused on belonging in their
social groups and people who have some
pro-social motives about keeping the
group together about doing things that
are good for the group so as i try to
argue in my book the righteous mind yes
we're selfish there's no doubt that we
often will do things to advance our own
self-interest at the expense of others
but we're also really groupish which
means we'll do all sorts of things to
advance our group at the expense of
others
basically we're tribal we evolved as a
tribal species and we're doing we have
all this software i would say all this
all these
predispositions these mental
predispositions for life in
in
tribes that are battling other tribes
and that's why it comes out so easily if
you look at the way boys organize
themselves when they get a fraternity um
the hazing rituals when you look at the
way it's especially clear and boys uh
the way street gangs organize themselves
girls tribalism is a little different um
but i would say this is that's why again
i love the jungian approach of
archetypes there's something there's
just this weird stuff that is pan-human
even if it comes out slightly
differently around the world there
really is a human nature and it comes
complete with a whole bunch of like
pre-designed ideas so there was a new
article i think it was published in
nature i'll try to find the link for it
it's about a year old
that that was based on high resolution
imaging of
neuronal connections and it's actually
reviewed in curtis kurzweil's book how
to build a mind i think that's the name
of it
and so it turns out that the cortex is
made out of these columnar structures
that are pre-organized units of neurons
and they're replicated across the entire
cortex it's basically the same structure
and like the the
older let's say connectionist idea was
that neurons that fire together wire
together right that that's heb and of
course that's pretty standard neurology
but the the columns are already
pre-wired so it's actually columns that
fire together that wire together but
there's but there's even more with the
high resolution scanning so it turns out
that underneath the columnar structure
there are these pre-built
highways that are connect connective
tissue that are pre pre-prepared so the
columns have the option to
connect to the to the underlying highway
and then that highway can connect to
other columns so it's as if
in implicit in the brain organization
and this is at the cortical level say
nothing of subcortical organization
there's already pre-existent
uh likelihoods that certain neurons will
fire will wire together yeah so and and
what else is cool is that this is
actually
architecturally quite
uh regular so they found that the these
superhighways are arranged in lines and
and and and in
at right angles to one another so it's
almost like a three-dimensional
structure of wired cubes that underlies
the neuronal structure so that's some
neurological evidence for the archetypal
idea so let me just explain to explain
to the viewers here why this isn't just
some like psychological geek
conversation this is actually really
relevant to a lot of the things that
that we'll be talking about and that
your audience probably cares about um
because one of the most contested ideas
in the social sciences is the idea of
innateness and the the idea is well if
something is innate
then it can't it can't vary
across societies and if it bears across
societies then it's not innate and if
gender varies if masculinity or
femininity vary across societies then
it's not innate it's socially
constructed but that's the wrong
understanding of innateness
the definition that i use comes from
gary marcus who's actually a
neuroscientist here at nyu he says
innate doesn't mean hardwired there's
almost nothing interesting that's
hardwired innate means structured in
advance of experience but then
experience can still revise it
and boy does that work for gender for
almost everything for fears for yeah
that's right almost everything that
we're not a blank slate about anything
and something i used to tell my students
at uva i taught at uva for 16 years is
you know everything's a social
construction
masculinity femininity
cancer
the sun
death everything there's a social
construction for you won't find a
society that doesn't have thoughts about
these things but the fact that societies
have social constructions tells us
nothing about whether there's not also
an underlying biological reality and in
almost all cases there is well otherwise
we wouldn't be able to communicate which
is one of eo wilson's comments right
when i mean wilson is the entomologist
who studied ants at harvard and also
wrote a number of books about
sociobiology that got him in trouble
with the radical leftists and he said
even if we could communicate with ants
there'd be nothing to say to each other
because their fundamental mode of being
in the world is based on motivations and
interests that are so different from
ours that there wouldn't be any
structure for communication and you can
kind of tell that with regards to the
animals that we make friends with right
we're much more likely to make friends
with animals who has a who have a
fundamental biological and social nature
that's very close to ours like dogs
because we can basically speak their
language even though not completely a
mammal language of love and you know i
miss you and i want to play with you
yeah that's right yeah exactly and
that's bonding yeah okay so back to
discuss back to discuss so um
so the fundamental thing that i learned
from paul rosen is to see us as these
amazing omnivores this is part of our
survival strategy even more than other
other apes we are just brilliant
omnivores and we have the omnivores
dilemma which is we've got to be
interested in all kinds of new stuff
we're not tied to any place we can roam
onto a whole new continent
so we're interested in stuff but stuff
has all kinds of toxins and microbes we
have to be careful about that stuff and
so these motives have to be in tension
and this is actually an interesting way
to understand the left right difference
you have to have both motives but if so
imagine two siblings one of whom is set
more towards trying new stuff seeking
out new stuff and the other is a little
more fearful and more like whoa no let's
you know let's not try that let's stay
with what's tried and true
i mean that's progressivism and
conservatives and that's the origins of
it and if you look at kids behavior at
the age of two or three
it does predict how they'll vote much
later not hugely but there is a clear
prediction there so um
so disgust is part of a regulatory
system about our engagement with the
world and whether we are just sort of
out there and you know we we seek out
variety and diversity we think diversity
is just a great thing or whether we want
a little more order structure
predictability
conservatives are neater than
progressives if you take photos of their
rooms um
you know you can actually you know
cleanliness and organization you can
predict how they vote um discussed it
turns out what's really cool about
discussed in modern politics is if you
look at all the different things that
we're fighting over especially in this
country our culture wars over you know
going back a few decades you know sex
drugs the flag immigration all of these
things
i have a study with my colleagues it was
led by sena koleva
in which we asked all these cultural war
attitudes of people and we also had
their scores on the disgust scale but
one of the foundations of morality is
sanctity and purity and it relates to
disgust what we found is that if you
know
if you know
um uh what people's left right how they
place themselves in the left right scale
you can pretty much predict where they
fall out on most culture war attitudes
except for those that load on or
implicate sanctity or purity so what i
mean is
flag burning okay do you think you know
do you think that people should have the
right to burn the american flag or the
country's flag as an expression as a
political action what do you think
people just give some answers on a one
to seven scale
and people on the right think you know
more like they say no people on the left
yes um people who score high on loyalty
are more likely to say no people who
lower on it say yes and that's even
taking account of where they're in the
left right dimension but here's the cool
thing
it's only if you add in the purity or
sanctity thing that you can really
understand what people are doing because
some people
see the flag
not as just a piece of cloth they see it
as having some innate essence some
something sacred about it which must be
protected
and so um so this is true even they
think of it as a unifying center exactly
that's right so if there's something
sacred and this is this is the central
piece of my work around politics and
morality it's the psychology of sanctity
if you hold something sacred
then your team circles around it and
it's only those who circle around with
you and sometimes literally circle
around like
muslims at prayer in mecca they
literally circle the kva circling is a
very primitive ancient it feels right to
circle something but even if even if you
do it symbolically or you all bow at the
same time
that binds you together children do that
with their mothers when they when they
engage in exploratory behavior right
well they use their mother as a center
of the world and children differ in the
degree to which they'll move outward
from their mothers so they move out
until they they they trip over their
their uncertainty threshold that's so
neat is it a distance like it's a
difference yeah yeah and so so the more
exploratory kids who are lower negative
emotion will go out farther before they
come back to their mother so the
mother's a center and you know that that
would be associated symbolically with
the idea of the center as a motherland
or potentially as a fatherland that's
right that makes sense so this way that
we're we are incredibly symbolic
creatures we're not just out to make as
much money as we can we're symbolic and
social creatures and this psychology of
sanctity or purity
has become really important not just on
the right it's always been important
for especially religious conservatives
we're beginning to see it even on the
campus left
and this is why i think we see some of
the odd things we see on campus
that the campus must be kept as a sacred
and pure space
one of the things that really alarms me
about what's happened on campus the last
couple years is that the older idea we
had that it's a place for contesting
ideas
it's a it's a zone of enormous choice
people can take what courses they want
say what they want it's kind of a
wonderful free-for-all with some with
norms of respect it's now becoming much
more of a religious zone
where the perimeter of the campus is the
the boundaries and within it's it
they're almost they're blasphemy laws
basically and i really started noticing
this when you look at the videos of the
middlebury uh protest when charles
murray spoke at middlebury
and as as everybody knows he was shouted
down so the students are chanting and
they're chanting in unison and it seems
like a religious revival meeting and
they're swaying and they're saying their
sacred you know racist sex is anti-gay
charles murray go away it's like a
ritual incantation um so that'll find
the space as safe and it's safe in a
kind of material way not yet so far all
this happening is they're binding
together they're moving and you know
synchronous movement and call and
response so it it's using a lot of
tropes from religion religious worship
but here's the cool thing
when the administrator i forget who it
is comes on to say
okay we have moved we're moving the talk
and then you hear a couple people
screaming out off campus off campus
and he says to another location on
campus and there's like oh no no
because
you know look no one had to go to this
talk so everyone could have just stayed
home
and the students did succeed in shutting
down the venue so they could have
declared victory but it's not a full
victory unless he is physically off the
campus we can't have him speaking on
campus because that defiles us that
pollutes us
we must shut that down
and that's where i started saying wow
this is like full-blown
psychology of religion durkheim sanctity
purity blasphemy
and that i think you know that doesn't
describe most students but that
describes sort of the core those who who
really have their identities wrapped up
in this movement okay so so with disgust
i wanted to i wanted to ask you a couple
of things about that so
you know the big five research into
political differences basically shows
that the liberals are high in trade
openness and low in trade
conscientiousness and the conservatives
are the reverse but we've fragmented
conscientiousness into orderliness and
industriousness with the big five aspect
scale and orderliness is strongly
associated with disgust
so so right sounds like it sounds like
freud right right exactly it does sound
a lot like freud but it but it also is
in accordance with your observations
that conservatives have neater spaces
for example so
so now and their meetings start on time
yes
yeah exactly right right so
so then the the nexus for political
belief seems to be openness so that's
that exploratory tendency that you
talked about exploration of ideas and
creativity and low
orderliness
and so then i thought well why in the
world would why would the political
nexus go across those dimensions which
are some relatively uncorrelated then i
thought
and this is in keeping with your work on
disgust is that it's an issue of borders
which of course seems more or less
self-evident in the wake of trump's
election when he talked about borders
but you might say and i think this is
reasonable that
the conservative is someone who wants
the borders between categories to remain
intact no matter what level of analysis
so it's borders from the highest
resolution level of cognition all the
way up to the actual physical borders of
of rooms towns
states countries all of that so the
borders should be thicker and the reason
they want that now there was a paper
published in applause one i don't know
if you saw it it was a couple of years
ago it was a mind-boggling paper it
should have been like front-page news as
far as i was concerned and what the
researchers did was between countries
and then within
provinces or states within countries
they correlated the level of
of
frequency of infectious disease
with authoritarian political beliefs
and found a walloping correlation it was
like 0.6 it was one of the highest by
the for for those of you who don't know
social scientists never discover
anything that's associated with anything
else at a correlation of 0.6 other than
heritability right other than
heritability yes and so what they found
was that the higher the prevalence of
infectious disease the higher the
probability of of totalitarian
authoritarian political attitudes and
then they controlled for governance
because one of the questions was was
this top-down authoritarianism or
bottom-up authoritarianism and the
answer was that it was bottom up okay
and so
i thought about that in two
from two perspectives simultaneously at
the time okay so we identified discussed
sensitivity with orderliness so it's a
say a fundamental subtrait
then i was reading this book that was
called hitler's table talk and it was a
it was the recordings of virtually
everything he said
at dinner from 1939 to 1942. yeah so
it's a spontaneous utterance to say and
um
it's full of discussions about jews and
gypsies and all the people he tormented
but what's really interesting is all the
language is discussed
no it's not fear
so so hitler's basic metaphor was that
the aryan race and country was a pure
body and then it was assaulted by
parasites right and then i remembered
what happened to the native americans
when the europeans showed up and shook
hands what happened was that 95 of them
were dead within 50 years right because
of smallpox and measles and so
that
that border issue that separates
conservatives from liberals let's say as
the conservatives say
the novel is potentially contaminated
it's not so much that it's dangerous
that's different that's fear it's
contaminating and the liberals say hold
on a minute if you make the borders too
thick then information can't pass
through exactly that's the omnivorous
dilemma right there right right and and
then since we have a biological
architecture on which our cognitive
platforms are erected we have the same
attitude towards abstract information
which would be ideas that we do to
things like food or or illness right
right and so we can think of an invading
idea or a polluting idea or
contaminating idea that's right i'm a
big fan of george lakoff metaphors we
live by uh that we yeah we use our
bodily our bodily schemata to think
about abstract things like politics and
like what our policies should be about
borders and immigration uh there's a
canadian psychologist mark schaller he
and his colleagues have developed what
they call an account of these the
behavioral immune system yeah right we
don't just try to you know
microbes killed probably many more of
our ancestors than did lions and tigers
and bears and so
whoever can keep themselves and their
children from being exposed to fatal
illnesses wins the evolutionary game and
so a lot of that is judging carefully
about people is he dangerous is she
dangerous and that's both for sexuality
for contact for all kinds of association
um so yeah in a lot of ways our emotions
uh and our bodily interactions structure
how we think and feel about about social
media well even with the black death in
europe i mean so the black death
occurred in europe when the europeans
started to move around the world and
they brought back rats that were
infected exactly so so what you saw
there was both of those forces at work
at the same time so the european
expansion produced a tremendous
interchange of ideas from all around the
world that's globalization but it wiped
out somewhere between 30 and 60 percent
of the population at the same time
so wouldn't it be good if in every
society or every organization we had
some people who specialized in
specialized in saying hey what are the
opportunities and then we had other
people who specialize in saying well but
what are the risks and it just so
happens that a lot of people have
trouble doing all that in themselves
when we have systems that are well
constituted with people who have
different personalities and different
motives and goals we actually can get
better outcomes we can have a discussion
between them yeah well that's exactly
why that it's for that precise reason
that that i've been so interested in
free speech as a as a value because well
even on the economic front it's pretty
obvious if you look at things
economically that the entrepreneur types
who start businesses are lumped in with
the liberal creative types we've done a
lot of work on the prediction of
entrepreneurial behavior and ability and
it's openness that's the big predictor
it's not the only one it's openness and
iq fundamentally but for managerial and
administrative expertise it's oh it's iq
and conscientiousness so the liberals
start businesses and and but they can't
run them because their their their
interests flip and they don't have the
organizational ability and the
conservatives can run them but they
can't continue to transform and expand
them
yin and yang yin and yang yep
so so one more thing about what happened
in nazi germany that that's very
relevant and interesting because it's
it's useful to get these motives right
you know
first of all if if something disgusts
you if something if you're afraid of
something then you run away from it or
you freeze but if something disgusts you
you try to burn it or dick or kill it
right you try to get rid of it or expel
it that's that's right you want to get
it away and destroy it
so when hitler first came to power he
put in a bunch of public health schemes
like he had vans that went around and
screened people for tuberculosis then he
went on a factory cleanliness uh
campaign
so the factories were supposed to be
tidied up and he washed he bathed about
four times a day by the way and was also
a great worshiper of willpower which is
associated with orderliness and seems
maybe to be associated with disgust
sensitivity in some way that isn't yet
understood yeah yeah
i don't i don't understand that
connection either so they he convinced
factory owners in germany to get rid of
the rats and the might and the mice and
the and the insects in the factories and
also to clean them up and beautify them
but the gas they used to clean up the
factories was zyklon a
and it was the variation of that gas
cyclone b that was then used in yeah so
you could see this ramping up so it was
yeah absolutely so it was public health
then it was
social cleanliness then he went into the
asylums and cleaned them up and so it
was just this expansion of of who was
contaminated and who was impure
and i think also his fascination with
fire and his use of fire symbolism was
also associated with that with that
appeal to purification because the whole
idea of purification by fire is a very
ancient idea
so
okay so
so how did your work on disgust change
the way that you looked at things
fundamentally i mean you gave some
indication of that already but what else
has it changed
um so
since i was coming out of a of a
psychological literature that was very
focused on on sort of secular
secular ethics about
justice and fairness
and then i began studying disgust and
looking at the broader moral domain that
almost all societies have
that then also led me to think about
well okay if disgust is a reaction to
things that seem to
be degrading so an interesting element
of discussion is this notion of
degradation that there are always these
vertical metaphors um
in which discuss brings us down and and
discussed so a lot of some religious
practice in judaism and islam and and
hinduism is about preparing your body to
approach god and
purification and so that led me to think
well if there's an emotion which is
about seeing our lower base or animal
biological nature
is there an opposite emotion is there an
emotion of that we feel when we see some
manifestation of a higher nobler nature
and i was just beginning to think this
when i moved to uva i got my first job
at the university of virginia 1995 and i
read uh the set of thomas jefferson's
letters and in one letter he describes
he describes the feelings you get from
reading great fiction
he advises a cousin of his that he
should buy fiction for his library not
just you know serious works of law and
philosophy
and he described he says
doesn't uh he describes the feeling of
of
of having your sentiments be elevated
does it not dilate your breast or give
you an open feeling in your chest when
you see these acts of beauty and
kindness and gratitude i thought wow
that's exactly it
and so because i've been studying
disgust i then started studying its
opposite
which i and some others called moral
elevations so there's this kind of
vertical metaphor of elevation and
degradation
that maps onto the body too with regards
to that's right high low uh clean dirty
um yeah it's it's a beautiful pairing
and so having this language of elevation
and disgust just really has helped me
see a lot of things i just i just see a
lot of things happening it allows me to
like even you know manipulate like if
i'm applying for a grant proposal like i
can get very good at like having an
elevating ending and you know to
uh to you know end with a note of uplift
um
and so it just brought it just broadened
my thinking about morality and this was
around 1995 and so again it just
prepared me
and i'd already been to india by that
point i spent three months doing
research in erisa in eastern india
so it just broadened my thinking and
that's what allowed me finally to
understand conservatives because i had
always been on the left i hated ronald
reagan um
i thought republicans were stupid and
evil and it was only when i'd gone to
india and really tried to understand a
traditional
religious hierarchical gender stratified
society tried to understand it in their
terms i didn't try to just bring in my
own
my own western left you know
left-leaning perspectives
that i was and this was all under the
guidance of richard schwader my post-doc
supervisor at the university of chicago
where did a postdoc
um it was only then that i was able to
to sort of get inside their minds and
their moral system and see that there
were alternative moral worlds they each
had their own logic and that was the
metaphor i came to you know at the time
you know the matrix movies were very
popular so the metaphor of the matrix as
a consensual hallucination made a lot of
sense so i came up with the idea of just
speaking about moral matrices whichever
different matrices that are grounded in
biology and
biology in the sense that gives us the
potential it's like the building blocks
of this matrix can't be just anything
that comes it comes from our experiences
our embodied experiences and again
george lakoff is the master of that
thinking
and so it was only then
that that i was able to now listen to
conservative talk radio and christian
religious radio and see rather than just
saying oh those stupid terrible people
say like oh wow yeah you know i can see
that they're striving for a certain
version right right so you started to
understand their metaphorical language
essentially that's right and that was
like kind of like my you know i know
great awakening or scales falling from
my eyes but you know since well it took
a few more it took a number a lot more
years but eventually i kind of just like
pulled out the implants from my eyes and
i stopped seeing everything so through a
partisan lens and i'm not on any side
now i'm just trying to understand what
the hell it is well it's really useful
it's really useful to understand that
there are actual reasons why people see
the world differently and that you can't
just easily say that one is right and
the other is wrong because the liberals
are correct when it comes to borders
that if you thicken them too much and
diminish the information flow you risk
making the society so static that any
radical environmental transformation
will sink it it's the case but the
conservatives are right in that you pay
a big price with regards to newcomers
and new information with regards to risk
to exposure to contaminating well to
contamination period but also to
contaminating ideas and so then i've
always thought you know the the
environment itself moves back and forth
like a snake in some sense and what
we're trying to do is stay on the center
of its back and the only way we can do
that is by people by having people pull
to the right and say be careful and
people pull to the left and say well
yeah but be open
with that dialogue and the the exchange
of information that that dialogue allows
we can maybe specify the center of that
moving target and stay and stay
well and stay on the back let's see yeah
okay so that's a really complicated
metaphor with the snake but i think it's
it's a perfect way in to what's going on
on campus and to why viewpoint diversity
is so important because that's i agree
exactly with what you just said and
so what i the view that i've come to in
studying moral psychology
is that
we is that humans are ultra-social apes
um we we evolved to live in these small
groups that are fighting with each other
uh we evolved to have these low-level
animistic religions that's
our steady state that's the way we were
for at least 100 000 years or much more
probably closer a million in some form
um so that's sort of our design that's
what we were designed for in a sense
um
and in that sense we're as individuals
really kind of stupid tribal creatures
designed to do post-hoc reasoning
but
if you put us together in the right way
with the right checks with the right the
right systems
the whole can be vastly smarter than the
components that go into it which is true
of the brain too the brain is composed
of neurons each neuron's really a kind
of stupid little switch
but you put them together in the right
way and you get something really
brilliant and in the same way
i don't know all the history here but my
understanding is that science begins or
well
the culture of science the scientific
revolution begins in europe
uh in the 17th century as you begin
getting you get the printing press so
people can share their ideas but you get
communities of people who are
challenging each other's ideas and
that's what makes it so brilliant is
that is that people have to do their
best we're really bad at disconfirming
our own ideas it's very hard to make
it's very hard to do that but you put
your ideas out there and then
everyone else is motivated to challenge
them and so if you put us together in
the right way the truth comes out and so
adversarial systems of law journalists
know this they have to listen to both
sides scientists know this social
scientists should know this okay what
happened
well
um the academy has has always leaned
left in the 20th century but leaning
isn't a problem
so people think oh viewpoint diversity
we need we need everybody we need nazis
we need every no we don't need everybody
what we need is no orthodoxy that's
what's fatal orthodoxy
so if you have uh if you have a field
like sociology or social psychology in
which it's two or three to one left to
right that's totally fine with me that's
totally fine uh because if someone makes
some claim that's just like
ideologically blind
someone will say uh you know common
sense other evidence that you've missed
and then the system works
but what what i learned when i started
down this road in 2011 i gave a talk
at the big conference of social
psychologists i gave a talk about this
problem that we're losing our diversity
that i i could only find one
conservative in the entire field and i
gave a talk on this um
and um
um and
so what i've learned since then is that
the ratio in psychology was between two
to one and four to one left right all
the way up to the early nineties we've
gathered together all the studies we
could find so all the way up to the
early 90s it's only three or four to one
left to right which would be okay
um but then between 1995 or 4 and 2010
it goes to
14 to 1. do you have any idea why yes
and why that time
yes so um so you get the same story
whether you look at republican democrat
ratios or liberal conservatives they
tell the same story so the two the big
things going on there are one
is that the greatest generation which
had a lot of republicans um so a lot of
men go off to world war ii they they're
on the gi bill they enter the academy in
the 1950s a lot of them are conservative
or republican
so you have a lot of them but in the 60s
and 70s one of the main reasons to go to
grad school in the social sciences is
either a to stay in school to escape the
vietnam war draft or b to fight for
social justice and against racism so in
sociology and psychology in particular
political science maybe i'm not sure you
get a huge influx of left-leaning people
who are there to pursue social justice
so you know the motives are fine
and if it was balanced it'd be totally
fine
but
as you get these young junior people on
the left come in in the 70s and 80s and
then you get the older people that are
more politically balanced retiring in
the 80s and 90s by the time you get to
the late 90s it's all baby boomers and
so do you get a do you get a positive
feedback loop developing in there like
you said if it's like three to one it's
okay but maybe when it hits four to one
it goes to like 20 to one then you stick
exactly so you then you so
then you start getting hostile climate
so i wrote a review paper on this with
uh with joe duarte and phil tetlock and
lee justin jared crawford um
and um
and we uh
so we reviewed everything that we could
find and we concluded that most of
what's going on is self-selection that
is people on the left are more open to
experience they're always going to
gravitate towards get self-selection but
then there's really good evidence that
there's also hostile climate i mean it's
undeniable now that if you are not on
the left in a grad program there's just
constant little subtle or not so subtle
reminders that you don't belong and look
in the academy we're all about saying
hey
if there are subtle hints here and there
you can't succeed right i mean that's
what we do for a living is we we say
that little things will stop people
well little things are put in the way of
anyone who doesn't fit politically
uh and so you do get hostile climate you
do get over discrimination there's
evidence of that and then there is also
it is part of the story here that what
it means to be a conservative in the 90s
and especially 2000 has changed so um it
is true that
you know that that the conservatives
were not in any way anti-science um
until much more recent times now
actually both sides are anti-science
about different sciences but um in
america the the right wing the
republican party
ha
it's controversial but i do believe that
the polarization starts with the right
moving further out so what it means to
be conservative to be
anti-anti-evolutionary which is actually
what's happening on the left now too
exactly yeah so as well as modern like i
talked to brett weinstein the other day
and you know he one of his claims is
that
evolutionary biology has something in it
to offend everyone
so it's a it's a science that's very
likely to be targeted by extremists you
also brought up something that actually
touches on the eye on the difficult
problem of how it is that you might
define someone who's ideologically
possessed let's say or ideologically
rigid because the idea was that
you can make a valid case for the
utility of free information flow and and
the free flow of people that would go
along with that and you can make a good
case for the danger of that and so the
idea might be that if you're only making
a case for the danger of that then
you're tilted too far to the right and
if you're only making a case for the
utility of that then you're tilted too
far to the left exactly that's right and
so we can look at immigration as a nice
example there's a recent essay in the
atlantic i think it was by peter beinart
where he
he reviews
he starts with a lot of quotes that are
pretty nuanced positions about
immigration from barack obama paul
krugman a bunch of other people on the
left who used to be able to say on the
one hand you know compassion
economic on the other hand you know we
have to have a legal process and there's
a threat to low-wage workers so
people on the left used to be able to
talk about immigration and talk about
the pros and cons the pluses and minuses
but bine art shows how in the last four
or five years you can't if you so much
as suggest that well maybe
immigration is on net good but it might
have some deleterious effects on certain
classes of low-wage american workers you
could get in big trouble right because
that's instantly prejudicial
because immigration has become a sacred
topic so this is the key thing that i
want everyone to keep in mind
we are fundamentally religious creatures
we're built for religion
and it's a great achievement to create a
scientific establishment and an academic
establishment that keeps that way of
thinking out scientific thinking is not
natural thinking religious thinking is
natural thinking and what's happening to
us in the last few years especially is a
flooding in of religious thinking and so
let's get a bunch of social scientists
talk about immigration what are they
going to do look at the data weigh up
the pluses and minuses no
they're going to
many of them feel they're on a team and
that team is fighting the right the
right is anti-immigrant it includes
racist elements therefore that justifies
us in being pro-immigration
and social sciences are always there's
always ambiguity there's always
conflicting studies yeah there's
multiple causal factors is that always
in the social science study that's right
so binary's point was that the left used
to be able to think straight about
immigration clearly it had a you know it
was generally pro-immigration but it
used to be able to think straight but in
the last few years a religious orthodox
mindset has overtaken it okay so we
might as well also point out that it's a
primordial religious mindset right
because i mean there are i don't mean
christian or jewish i mean
ancient tribal small scale lots of gods
right right well so then one of the
things that you might suggest is that
when you throw out a sophisticated
religious
structure an unsophisticated religious
structure comes in to fill the gap i do
so that's true okay okay so that's
definitely worth thinking about so yeah
that's right so that's right the thing
to right with religions we have to
clarify uh fundamentalism is the problem
not religion and so if you think it's
close to tribalism that's right if you
get a fundamentalist you know i'm happy
to say and if you have people applying
to a grad program in psychology
and i find out that they're christian
that's fine there's no problem but if
they're fundamentalist christian
i would think well let's say let's say
it's not psychology suppose it's you
know geology so someone applies to a
geology program they're a fundamentalist
young earth creationist
are you gonna admit them no i don't
think you should they're not able to do
the right kind of thinking
based on what we know to be the case
they're they're they're not in this
scientific paradigm not necessarily
that's right so so if we wouldn't admit
a fundamentalist christian to a geology
program why would we admit someone who
is just as fundamentalist about certain
moral and political issues into a
sociology program or into a psychology
program if they come in knowing what the
right answer is committed to that right
answer
likely to get angry at anyone who
contravenes that right answer
um
and and showing signs of
closed-mindedness i don't think they
belong in a graduate yeah i guess the
question is how in the world do you set
up mechanisms to ensure that you're not
swamped by fundamentalists of any sort
so those are people who are reducing
everything to a single cause it's
something like that how can you
implement a structure that protects the
organization against that without the
structure itself becoming
totalitarian you know because these
things these things spin out of control
so fast yeah but so you know i think
what we have to realize in the academy
is that we face i think we face an
existential crisis um
we rely an enormous amount on public
goodwill we get enormous tax subsidies
direct research support
and recent polling shows that while
democrats have always had a higher
opinion of the universities than
republicans until two years ago
everybody thought universities are a
good thing they make life better so
americans have been very supportive of
higher education there have been rising
gripes on the right but it's only
between 2015 and 2017 that now
republicans go from saying mostly
universities are good things in two
years they go way down and say
universities are bad things they're
making things worse now how is this news
greeted
pundits on the left are saying oh those
republicans are so anti-science look how
ignorant they are they now hate
universities
come on anybody who's been watching the
news anybody who's seen the mobs the
shout downs the illiberal behavior you
know the metaphor i use is like you know
americans on the right and left are
really supportive of the military we
have it's one of the few institutions
that we still hold in highest team on
both sides and so the republicans more
than democrats so suppose you had gallup
polling
showing republicans like the military
more than democrats but both really like
it then suddenly in 2015 we started
seeing video from all over military
bases the military academies in which
the the military leaders are overtly
right-wing they're they're they're
saying terrible things about leftists
and progressives and the midshipmen and
the cadets and everybody is mobbing the
occasional liberal and to behaving in a
really despicable scary and intimidating
way
what do you think the left would now
think about the military obviously
support for the military would plummet
that's what's happening in america with
universities we are losing the support
of half the country this is
unsustainable especially in red states
where
they control the purse strings
so i think we have a major crisis i
think we've got to go into crisis mode
and we've got to clean up our act so
just as we're doing in psychology with
replication project
we recognized that our methods weren't
good enough and we're
doing a crash course
thanks to brian nosick and others the
open science project we're really trying
to improve our game thank god we need to
i think we have to do the exact same
thing about partisanship um and our
duties okay so let's talk about
heterodox academy because you set that
up this organization that you should
tell everybody about in in precisely to
deal with this issue and so i'd like i'd
like to know about
it how it's growing what it's doing what
your aims are all of that yeah so i gave
this talk in 2011 laying out
the fact that we have no more
conservatives in social psychology and
why this makes it hard for us to find
truth and in the months after that a few
social psychologists resonated with the
message they said wow i think that i
think you're right i have some data on
this so the five of us
six of us
wrote this paper it came out in
behavioral and brain sciences oh uh
charlotta stern i'm sorry was the sixth
one that i forgot to add in before um we
got this paper published in behavioral
brain sciences it came out it was sort
of online in 2014
but it came out for good in the summer
2015 which coincidentally was the same
summer that my article came out with
greg lukianov called the coddling the
american mind that was about things
going on with undergrads but our concern
was entirely faculty was just the nature
of the academic community the research
community so we got these two things
going on summer of 2015. um and then
that summer i hear from
uh nick rosencrantz a law professor who
says we have the same problem in law
and he's not gonna be worse in law well
it's really bad in canada in law okay
because and as he points out we're
training all these students
they never meet a conservative then they
have to go argue cases in front of
judges half of whom were appointed by
republicans they have no idea what a
conservative thinks this is malpractice
we've got to train so and i hear from a
sociologist chris martin same thing in
sociology so the three of us said hey
you know this is a big problem for the
whole academy have you looked at
faculties of education oh my god those
are the worst by worst i don't know the
numbers but in terms of the
vindictiveness that the incredi the
pressure
put on any non-conforming opinion
my impression i don't have data but my
impression from the letters i get is
that uh education schools and social
work schools
are the worst that's exactly in keeping
with my my understanding as well it's
hard to tell which of those two are
worst i would say it's the faculties of
education because they have a direct
pipeline to kids well in terms of their
effects yeah yes far more pernicious
yeah that's right yeah but but equally
equally warped let's say but but more
pernicious and and the things that are
happening in the canadian education
system as a consequence of that are so
reprehensible
because it's happening here too with
these ideas filtering down to high
school i've been so focused on college
now we're discovering the problem is
actually baked in the liberal attitudes
are often baked in by the time they
arrive yes and purposefully like in in
canada increasingly the the the radical
leftists have control over curriculum
development and they're starting to
develop social justice curriculums which
is what they call them
for for kindergarten kids
so it's really so let's finish up the
head of the academy then we'll get back
to the earlier grades so uh so
originally three of us decided to put up
a website i invited all the other
authors from the the bbs paper we
invited a few other people working on
this and so for the first year we had
this project it was called
heterodoxacademy.org
we put the site up on about september
10th i think it was
and it was just a community of
researchers who are studying
the problem of the lack of viewpoint
diversity well five days later the
protests start at missouri so these are
racially motivated protests or protests
about racial
insensitivity and racial problems at
missouri
um and at first it seemed like this is
just a missouri problem but coming in
the wake of course of of ferguson and
all the videos we saw of unarmed black
men being killed by police
[Music]
a lot of these concerns spread to other
universities the protests aren't just
about race but it was that fall of 2015
especially the yale protest
when the president of yale validates
their narrative that yale is a racist
place we have to reform yale
then it spreads nationally and now
suddenly this is not just a faculty
issue anymore so even though ted rocks
academy we're mostly focused on the
faculty we're now seeing it's a complex
ecosystem with all kinds of forces
acting on universities so that between
2015 and 2017 the danger of speaking
honestly about what you think about an
academic or intellectual proposition has
skyrocketed the risk of being mobbed
ostracized formally investigated by
title ix people for example headline
people um we're here we're sitting here
at nyu go to any bathroom i'll show you
on this floor go to any bathroom there's
a sign telling students exactly what
number to call to report you or me if we
say something that is that someone takes
to be a bias act oh so you have bias you
have bias investigation teams here
that's right see we haven't got to that
point that particular point in canada
yet so i think we're farther ahead down
that path in some ways but not quite as
far in others yeah that's really that's
really unbelievable so things are
changing very very fast it's not at all
schools but then again things are
changing so fast we don't really know we
don't have good data on what's going on
um what i can tell you though is that at
heterodox academy when we started out in
there was a lot of suspicion a lot of
people on the left were afraid like oh
is this some right wing group now very
few of us are actually on the right um
but because we end up mostly speaking up
for libertarians and conservatives who
are attacked or silenced
you know people will think oh we must be
right-wing but we're not i mean i'm i've
never voted for republican in my life
i've never given money to a republican
campaign um i'm now increasingly calling
myself a liberal now that we see
illiberalism flourishing
but so when we started out there was a
lot of suspicion of us from
many professors but now that it's clear
that the problems these are not just a
few anecdotes this is the new normal um
and it's not just in the universities as
you pointed out that's right it's like
and it's not just in the us it spread
when uh in 2015 i thought it was
uniquely american problem yeah boy it's
in canada and the uk yeah and australia
well in new zealand that's right it is a
uniquely anglosphere problem this is
really interesting it's not on the
continent very much at all what about in
the nordic countries no i mean they have
so political correctness you have lots
of places the unique thing that
identifies this new culture is linking
the political correctness with the sense
of fragility and this is something
america's pioneered the idea that um so
in britain they've always had um no
platforming they call it so if there's
an and there was an actual british
national party some actual fascist party
you know so if if a bnp member is going
to speak on campus you mob him you shut
it down no plat don't give him a
platform so you know you've had
passionate politics certainly since the
60s so that's not new and that's
everywhere
what's new is the american idea that if
someone says something and it could be a
sincerely expressed idea not a racist
rant just like well i don't know i think
that maybe hormones do affect gendered
behavior
can you say that
well what if someone takes that as as
somehow
essentializing gender and then saying
that women are inferior or whatever yes
well that happened to james damore for
example exactly exactly so um
so that's what's new is the idea that if
someone says something that someone a
member of a protected or marginalized
group is offended by that person is
harmed if that person is harmed
we must protect that person and more
ominously just in the last year or two
it's not just that they're harming their
suffering it's that this was violence
yes right violence yeah well that's part
of the post-modern narrative that that
and this would be something to power
this is so dangerous the the the
crossing the line into into violence it
just occurred to me just like yesterday
i was thinking about this wait the state
is supposed to have a monopoly on
violence right but if speech especially
his speech and her speech and the people
the speech of those people in that
academic movement or on that
if there's species violence well the
state is supposed to have a monopoly on
their speech then and
um and if it's violence well then we
have a right to use violence back the
state doesn't have monopoly on our
violence because our violence is you
know is morally motivated
so just the the orwellian and
authoritarian implications of this move
once you say that speech is violence
you're unlocking you know you're opening
pandora's box i mean you're five steps
down the road to hell and i'd say we're
about seven steps down the road
so okay so you're you're that concerned
about it okay so now tell me how many
how many members uh if you you don't
have to discuss any of this obviously
but how many members of heterodux
academy are there now we have 1300
members so once we opened up so
originally it was just for researchers
who were studying this problem but we
had lots of people wanting to join and
so we said well okay why not and so we
just said all right if as long as you're
a professor
that is you have a phd you're living
more or less the life of a professor you
have a university affiliation so we now
take adjuncts if they have a phd
we take postdocs basically if you're in
the guild if you're living the life of a
professor and you're concerned
about
the
rise of intimidation frankly if you're
concerned that our wonderful institution
i love
i love being a professor i love the
academy and i feel like it's not just
losing public respect it's losing its
ability to
to function it's losing its ability to
teach and do research on politicized
topics
and there are more politicized topics
all the time that's that's right and
there are a few in the natural sciences
not many but there are some in the
natural sciences as well anyway my point
is we're now growing very rapidly and
something i'm very excited by is
since we've started having more violence
on campus with beginning with birth and
middlebury we're seeing a pervasive
sense among people on the left that
there really is this problem here that
something has to be done and so we are
finding much more acceptance now um from
professors on the left so i like to
think about there's the liberal left
which is the great majority and there's
the illiberal left we did a factor
analysis of politically correct beliefs
and found exactly that and that the and
that the ill liberal left was also high
in orderliness that's interesting that's
the authoritarian exactly predisposition
yeah and also
kind of markedly decline
was also characterized by a marked lack
of verbal intelligence oh that's it so
yeah it was like the correlation was
about 0.4 well that oh that's beautiful
that's beautiful because one of the
simplest formulations i've heard a
really great formulation from mark lilla
so mark wrote this fantastic op-ed the
new york times week after trump was
elected saying identity politics is a
really foolish thing to do it pushes
lots of people over to trump's side
identity politics is part of the problem
well he writes this op-ed and one of his
fellow professors at columbia i forget
how she does it but she basically says
something about the you know the mask
with eye holes falls from his face like
you know he's a ku klux klan member or
something like that
and so lila
lila who is in the humanities he's an
intellectual historian lil has this
simple formulation he says that's a slur
not an argument
and once i had that simple formulation i
realized wow that's almost all the
pushback i've ever gotten
it's somehow you know oh you know you're
winking at nazis or your
yeah that's happened to me over and over
i was just my neighborhood was just
posters you saw that
the intimidation so so this is really
key we're supposed to be all about
you can say anything you want you can
make any argument you want if you can
support it
if you can back it with reasons this is
critical thinking this is what we're
supposed to train our students to do
well and it's not only that you can say
anything but you can say it there's a
boundary on that which especially if
you're a scientist less so in the
humanities but if you're a scientist the
things you say have to be vetted by
people who are going to be critical of
them right so so not only not only
that's right there's accountability
that's built into it that's right so i
didn't mean to say you can say no i know
any idea you want if you can back it up
what we're seeing with anything
politicized is it's not about backing it
up students are learning rhetorical
techniques to link their enemies to
something racist well something
contemptible sometimes
disgusting
and that and that and those are the
things that are not only worthy of being
destroyed but that you have a moral duty
to destroy exactly so that's right so
it's almost like the immune system yeah
exactly works but there's some cell that
tags a cell
as you know enemy enemy and once that
tag is put on the cell that attracts
other i forget what kind of cell too
yeah
so we should look into this this
metaphor of the immune system yeah
because you know once once you're
labeled as a racist
students don't have to read you that it
doesn't matter what you actually say you
will now be attacked well it's also too
that once you're labeled that way if
someone defends you the label is
contagious that's how we know we're in
this super religious territory of witch
hunts that if you stand up for someone
you are tagged and then you will be
mobbed right and that's the news so much
disease exactly that's why there's so
much cowardice on campus among both
students and faculty people are afraid
to stand up even if the majority think
that what's going on is nuts or is
unfair they're afraid to stand up and
that's in part due to social media
because it's just i mean students today
have been raised with various platforms
that make it easy for people to join in
attack someone they look at who liked
what so if in that article we just saw
on read
there was a bit of a counter-revolution
at read
the students had to get together somehow
and decide should i like that post how
about if we all like it at the same time
then we'll get in less trouble okay like
okay so to what degree
so let's talk about the aims of the
heterodox academy so you've brought
people together who are
in principle interested in a diversity
of opinions and but
but in what manner is that going to be
utilized to to to
i don't want to use the word combat but
to but to deal with this emergent
problem of ideological rigidity in the
university yes so uh two useful concepts
here one is the emperor's new clothes um
we all know that story um
even if most people even if everybody
sees this is nuts the emperor's walking
around no clothes they're afraid to say
it until one person says it so and this
is also the ash experiment everybody
says that that line is the same as that
line it's obviously not true if one
person
says the truth then nobody conforms
after that right so the mere presence of
a group of people who say you know what
we actually need a diversity of opinions
and the fact that on our site we'll
publish things so sometimes when
professors are mobbed like when brett
weinstein you know was mobbed you know
so i wrote an essay that stood up for
him uh we've done that for some of them
it's happening so fast i can't keep up i
can't i've got books to write like you
know every week there's some new member
who's getting mobbed and so we're going
to develop a team of people who will
write but just knowing that there are
people who will stand up for you um
knowing that there are people who will
say wait a second um you know this is
not what we do in the academy so that's
one thing we just stand up for each
other
two is we develop products that we think
can basically fix the situation so one
of our products is called the campus
expression survey it's a survey designed
to actually measure who is afraid of
speaking up
about what topics and why what are they
afraid of and it turns out everyone's
afraid of the students more than the
faculty
uh they're afraid mostly to talk about
race what about the administrators
everyone's afraid of the students
they're afraid of the students oh so i i
don't have we have not surveyed them
i've only surveyed students i don't okay
okay but from what we hear
um
people are afraid of
of the students um
you know well that's also appalling in
its own manner like was that really of
leadership where yeah that's for sure
they let those kids come into the
classroom the actual classroom and
disrupt a class on an ongoing basis i
mean for months yes and i couldn't
understand that exactly i mean
my response to that would be
first i would tell them to leave second
i would call campus security third if
something wasn't done about it i just
wouldn't teach the class so i don't
understand like it seems to me that it's
also up to individual professors to draw
a line which is that if you're being
intimidated by students
why do you why do you show up and teach
the class i don't understand that yeah
so um again
people are afraid to stand up if it
means that people will call you a racist
yeah but god i mean it's it's weird in
that situation though because it's
carried to you you're also afraid to go
to your class you know and there's a
much more proximal threat there that's
what i mean that's what i'm most alarmed
by is the rise of intimidation
intimidation is now a factor in many
aspects of academic life and that's just
terrible that's completely incompatible
uh with what we do and who we are it's
especially it's especially appalling
given that whatever happens in the
university campuses you know like one of
the questions i've faced in canada is
well why should we care about what's
happening
in the in the ivy towers if you're going
to hire these people next year you are
well yeah well there it's the heart like
what's happening in the campuses is
going to happen in society in five years
it's already happened this is actually
an important point um i just gave a talk
at a at a big law firm here in new york
where they're very devoted to diversity
but they're doing it right they're
really thinking about diverse like why
is diversity good and save a whole month
on viewpoint diversity which is just
fantastic
and what i'm learning from talking to a
number of people in the business world
is that in the last year there are now
all these pressures
on leaders to endorse this condemn that
sign this open letter that's coming in
through human resources that's right
that's right but it's the same dynamic
we have on campus and the answer to it
so if anybody anybody watching here if
you run a business if you have friends
who are in business i think the only
the
there are only two stable equilibria
one is that every organization is just
either all right wing or all left-wing
but that would be disastrous so either
you just say okay we're on one side that
would be terrible
the other is what we call the chicago
principles of free expression the
university of chicago has the best
statement out there on how the
university provides a platform on which
multiple views can contest the
university does not take anyone's side
that's the only other stable alternative
and i think leaders need to do this in
business certainly at universities so
we're encouraging every university to
adopt the chicago principles because a
lot of what mass action is is an attempt
to compel the authority to come in on
your side and punish your enemies yeah
and so that has to stop so so how how
effectively is the chicago statement on
on
how effectively is the chicago statement
being disseminated how rapidly are
universities signing up or or um there
are a few signed on early in this whole
crisis um uh purdue they're about 10 or
15 that have that have endorsed it or
something like it
uh it's not enough to just endorse
something but if you have leadership
that's committed
to creating an open platform in which
people can disagree um and and i'm one
that's very encouraging
i've been invited by a number of
university presidents to come speak um
we have all kinds of innovations at head
rocks academy
uh to foster a more inclusive climate in
which people can actually
engage with difference
there's a lot of interest so i think the
university leaders were very slow to
react they didn't want to alienate
certain factions of students
but they're almost all reasonable people
they're almost all liberal left
um not a liberal they're horrified by
what's going on they know they're
sitting atop a powder keg they don't
want things to blow up in their face as
happened at evergreen so this brings us
to our our another product the one that
we're most excited by uh so we just went
online uh actually uh today uh it's
called the open mind platform if you go
to openmindplatform.org
you can find we've developed an app we
have a whole library of readings and
videos we've developed an app that
guides you through
we don't just say here's how to engage
with different viewpoints we start by
saying
why is it good and we make the case that
you need this everybody needs this
and two
um
we remind people
that we're all basically self-righteous
hypocrites we have quotes from wisdom
traditions around the world and we've
all heard this so just a little bit of
you know you can call it emotional
manipulation if you like but just
get people into a mindset in which
they're willing to say oh yeah whoa you
know calm down we're all we're all uh uh
i'm too self-righteous here and then we
then we teach them some psychology
about motivated reasoning and only then
do we teach them to engage with views
that are not their own so we've already
run this in about 15 or 20 classes
the results so far look promising that
at the end of it the measures show that
students are more open to other ideas so
the open mind platform we think is a
tool that
we think a lot of universities are going
to adopt there's a lot of interest in it
and if there's leadership if the
professors generally do support
viewpoint diversity and open inquiry if
we change freshman orientation so that
students are trained first and foremost
in how to
step back give people the benefit of the
doubt be open-minded if we do that first
yeah that's like behavioral
exposure to some degree right the idea
would be that if you're if you're afraid
or disgusted by something that you don't
understand the appropriate first
treatment first of all the treatment is
necessary because otherwise you'll
you'll isolate yourself in the ways that
you already described and second that
brief exposure voluntary exposure is
going to be the best curative
and that's the opposite of the safe
space idea where you need to be that's
right the safe space the safe space idea
is the worst thing you could possibly do
for the very people yeah exactly exactly
i mean psychology what you know
the psychology behind safe spaces and
microaggressions is just the exact
opposite of what we should be doing if
we want to create kids especially black
kids gay kids women whatever if you
think that they are vulnerable to more
stigma more conflict if you think that
they are vulnerable that's especially
when a safe space will be
temporarily pleasant but in the long run
bad for you right and that's the
critical issue too with regards to safe
spaces is that they're sacrificing the
medium and long term of the students
well-being let's say to the short-term
lack of fear and conflict they're
infantilizing them essentially
so yeah okay so all right so
i i was thinking about the the
discussion idea i've got a personality
test online now
that's based on this big five aspect
scale but it might be interesting as
something for us to think about to to
find people who are high in openness and
low in conscientiousness or orderliness
and offer them the opportunity to engage
in dialogue with people who have the
opposite personality traits you know
because
well first of all because they're going
to run into people like that always
right and and and maybe even establish a
relationship with them inadvertently and
so being able to tolerate that might
give them the kind of insight that you
said you developed when you realized
that the conservative ethos was based on
a reasonable but not complete set of of
of
beneficial axiomatic presuppositions so
all right so now this has pretty much
taken over your life this heterodox
academy
as well as the writing now you're
writing a couple of new books i
understand yeah so um so since so i was
in the psychology department at the
university of virginia for uh for 17
years
and when my book the righteous mind was
coming out i wanted to move to new york
city for a year so i could you know do
promotional work for it and i just had
my second child was just born and i knew
it would be hard to fly from
charlottesville so i just happened to
get a position a temporary position here
at stern at the business school
and when i first arrived i wasn't that
interested in business
but as soon as i got here occupy wall
street happened and suddenly it was like
everyone's talking about morality and
politics and capitalism and business and
then i started learning about the
history of capitalism and i knew nothing
about it was fascinating
and i started seeing how free enterprise
and free markets have helped
you know raise weight raise living
standards around the world yes radical
declines poverty in a staggeringly rapid
fashion that's completely
unprecedented especially since the year
2000 that's right so since so you know
here i was 48 years old discovering i
knew nothing about it was like when i
first learned about evolution like wow
this explains like everything in the
natural world and learning about
capitalism business explained everything
about the built world and and the world
that we actually live in um
and there was also all these business
scandals this was 2011 the wake of the
financial crisis and i saw a huge
opening to begin applying moral
psychology to help corporations have
better ethics
so i then everything i do is involves
applying moral psychology to help
complex systems work better so i've been
focused on political polarization and
governance for years before then and
that led to the righteous mind and then
i got here to stern they offered me a
job during that first year and i took it
and it's been fantastic it's been really
exciting it's like a whole new
you know almost like being back in grad
school a whole bunch of new things to
learn it must be a kind of a shock an
existential shock to be in a business
school in some sense no it's not it's
not a shock i mean it's a different
culture it's much more open in the sense
that it's so diverse like the things
people are doing there's not like a way
that we do things here and it's much
more open to applied projects to
actually to applied projects yeah and so
it was a perfect time for me like i just
you know the righteous mind that wraps
up like the first half of my career like
everything i did is in that book and now
it's time for something new and that new
thing was going to be
um
looking at how morality or moral
psychology both underlines or or or is
the foundation for our ability to do
capitalism like contracts reciprocity
all sorts of things and how our left
right divide
um from the righteous mind makes it hard
for us to figure out what's true like if
you raise the minimum wage does that
help or hurt the working poor right if
you're an economist on the left
obviously helps them if you're
economists on the right it obviously
hurts them because fewer than have jobs
and you can gerrymander the measurement
devices to produce the conclusions that
you want which is a big problem that's
right so i'm supposed to be writing a
book called three stories about
capitalism the moral psychology of
economic life and so i started traveling
around the world looking at how
development is going in various
countries i did a three-month trip to
asia in 2015 i came back from asia my
article came out with lukianov the
codling american mind the bbs article
was published uh and i thought okay now
i can get back to this you know he brand
this capitalism book and then the
universities kind of began melting down
in the fall and then we started rocks
academy and so yes it has taken over my
life it's it's basically a full-time job
in addition to trying to write um
the i'm also working on a book so
lukianov and i didn't want to turn our
article into a book because we thought
we'd said everything
but man have things been happening fast
and we've learned so much more since we
wrote that article and you wrote that
article when how long well we wrote it
in late 2014 and then we you know edited
it in early 2015 and it finally came out
in august of 2015.
and so in last october greg
wrote to me and said john i think i do
want to turn the article into a book
because we know so much more now and the
problem is so much more serious than it
was and the evidence my god the evidence
about mental the mental health crisis of
adolescence when greg and i wrote the
article we were you know
we saw lots of hints that depression and
anxiety were going way up yeah and we
think that's related to the the
overprotection
yeah let's okay so let's talk about that
just for a second then go back to the
book so i've got a dem potential
demographic explanation for that in part
well and i don't know if you guys have
looked into this or not well there
there's there's two things that i think
might be contributing to it
one is
two or three things one is the average
age at which children are uh
the average age at which people have
children has gone way up that's true
okay so why does that matter well
because i think people get more
conservative and cautious as they get
older a little bit but true but it's a
very small effect okay and wait a second
okay it's the having of the kids which
is what makes them more conservative
when you have kids you are more threat
sensitive you're more likely to vote for
the right-wing party so
just delaying child child uh childbirth
wouldn't okay what about what about
fewer siblings that would yes that's
part of it uh and this is what we're
seeing in asia too when you have a lot
of kids
you're not quite as worried you don't
have all your eggs in one basket well
and you can't be quite as worried and
the siblings raise each other that's
right right and then there's a lot of
things dominating straight that's right
exactly it's the free play and the
fighting the working things out for
themselves those are essential skills of
adulthood okay so could so then all
right so because the smaller family size
is part of it right well and then also
what's happening increasingly in schools
is that kids aren't allowed free play
and they're certainly not allowed rough
and tumble free plays exactly that's
right that's one of the biggest things
about so the two the there are three
giant there there are a lot of causes
it's i mean this is such actually it's
really a fun puzzle because it's like
the biggest social science puzzle of our
age what is happening that's making so
many of our systems go haywire and i'm
focusing on the university the big three
i would say are one is the loss of free
of unsupervised free play yeah um and
peter gray has been brilliant on this
he's at boston college showing how even
among young animals they have to
practice the skills for adulthood yeah
and getting in
showing that too exactly so getting in
conflicts and then dealing with it and
sometimes losing and you come back
having game in which there's a problem
but you have to work it out or the game
stops that's what kids always did yeah
it's only recently in the nine beginning
in the 90s that they're always
supervised because we're afraid if we
take our eyes off them they'll be
kidnapped and that was never a risk was
never a risk you know i've kind of
wondered about this gender flexibility
issue as a form of delayed fantasy play
you get freudian on me go ahead well
because because it looks to me like that
is you know when kids are little and
three and four say three to seven they
do a tremendous amount of identity play
you know they pretend they're animals
they pretend they're their parents they
they pretend they're girls if they're
boys they pretend they're boys if
they're girls like they really do a
tremendous amount of identity play
and one of the things that's been really
puzzling me is well what happens if that
isn't
um if they never have an opportunity for
that because they're not engaging in
fantasy play maybe it's just delayed
till adulthood oh that's interesting so
because play it's almost impossible to
overstate the importance of that rough
and tumble play and then the fantasy
play that enables you to adopt different
identities and then the negotiated games
that you talked about that enable people
to handle both both victory but even
more importantly loss that's right so
that's plausible that could well be i
know that i have no no opinion on but
the big three factors that i think
are explaining explain part what's
happening on campus are one the loss of
the unsupervised play so that the kids
have always there's always an adult
present and so they come to college and
they expect there to be an adult or deen
somebody if there's a conflict that's
one
two is social media which hit just as
igen so igen internet generation this is
gene twangy's work you know we used to
we used to think that um
we used to think that the millennial
generation ends in 1998 or 2000
but jean twangy shows
looking at four large data sets that
birth year 1995 kids born in 1995 and
after are really different their values
are different
they have much higher rates of anxiety
and depression especially the girls boys
have gone up girls have gone way up
and the reason seems to be that facebook
lowered its age
so in 2005 you had to be a college
student at a certain number of colleges
to get facebook in 2006 you could be any
11 year old who lies and says that she's
13 and you've got a facebook account
um
but then you're using on your parents pc
and in 2007 the iphone comes out and it
saturates the market faster than any
consumer product ever has so by 2010 or
11 a lot of adolescents have
have facebook and other social platforms
and this is just devastating especially
to girls because it's not texting
texting is just me to you you know
that's back and forth that's fine that
you know we when we were kids you called
your friends on the phone that's fine
the problem seems to be according to
twengy it's especially
platforms in which you put something out
and then you wait and see what everyone
says right and that especially is
damaging to girls who already are at
risk of eating disorders and image
disorders okay okay so so girls become
more susceptible to negative emotion
when they hit puberty well they're
too with regards to female aggression
so
you know
it's clearly the case that males are
more likely to be physically
damaging
aggressive than females are but what
females use is reputation savaging
that's right that's nikki trick's work
nikki crick passed away a couple years
ago showed that if you add it all up
boys and girls are equally aggressive
but the boy's aggression is more
physical the girls are more relational
so if you imagine a bunch of 13 14 year
olds
in their middle schools and then you
parachute in a whole bunch of iphones
everybody's got one in their pocket
what are the boys going to do they're
going to play video games that doesn't
hurt anybody
but the girls are going to use it to
amplify the social interactions so this
is
explanation i think it makes a lot of
sense so it's a it's a catastrophe it's
a crisis and we're really hurting
especially the girls um so we've got to
change something about that anyway but
social media is is possibly the largest
single reason why things are going
haywire on campus the third big factor
and do you think it's primarily facebook
or can you tell well it's it's a uh the
kids use a lot of different platforms
but from what i hear instagram
facebook snapchat it again the thing is
it's one to many that's what's bad it's
anything if if it's if it's you put
something out there and you see how many
people like it right that's what's best
right and there's always the threat that
it'll go viral in a terrible way so
that's like a hammer exactly there's a
sort of damage that is unlimited that's
unlimited damage unlimited downside to
saying something so what do you do so
they're all careful right right so i
don't know if i want to like that post
because
you know i could get in big trouble for
it right well the benefit to liking it
is minimal and the potential catastrophe
for distance unless you're expected to
like it in which case you better like it
because if you don't like it you'll get
in trouble so it's a much more of a mob
mentality kids are afraid you know i'm
not blaming the kids i'm very
sympathetic to them i mean these are my
kids they're you know my kids are 11 and
7 they're going to come up into this
so the kids have been raised in a in a
social environment that's much more
about mob
mob formation and mob attacks and mob
and defenses against mobs
and then so the third factor then is the
political polarization
and the purification of institutions so
if you imagine coming up in the 90s when
political polarization's going up we're
beginning to hate each other more across
party lines but it's not that hard not
that nasty but it's been getting much
much more hostile so that now if someone
like if someone is a if someone goes to
a campus republicans meeting if it's a
democrat who goes to a meeting of the
campus republicans has happened at uc
santa cruz a couple weeks ago um
and someone finds out you know that so
the the the hatred the cross-party
hatred is so much stronger now
and
many of our institutions are much purer
so if you went to college in the 90s
there might have been a few conservative
professors around
but now there aren't so as you said
before it's like exposure therapy if
you've never encountered a conservative
idea and then a conservative like
heather mcdonald comes to speak on your
campus well this is like a major immune
response problem we've got to get the
tribe together and mob her and and you
know shut her down
um so
those are the i mean there are many
other reasons but the loss of
unsupervised play social media and
rising polarization those are the three
big ones right well those are big
problems especially the loss of
unsupervised play it's not it's not
obvious at all how that might be
addressed yes it is okay good good
everyone should buy
everyone should just buy lenore
skanesie's book free range kids and then
they should loosen up and give their
kids more unsupervised time now you
can't do this alone you'll be arrested
yeah i tried to get my son to go out
across the street to you know buy
groceries when he was you know nine
years old yeah and he'd say like but you
know daddy people look at me funny there
are no other kids out there
and so lenore has started a fantastic
organization called let grow so if if
viewers go to
letgrow.org okay we'll put all this in
the description all of these things
right so i'm on the board of it as an
advisor peter gray an expert on play is
on the board and they're doing these
simple things simple simple things like
you convince a school to just
open up the playground an hour early
or keep it open after school why should
kids always have organized activities in
soccer practice just give them a place
to play where there's a nurse available
if someone gets hurt there is an adult
but he's not supervising he's just over
there right so don't worry parents there
is an adult but beyond that can do what
they want
and they just started this a few weeks
ago and the results are fantastic the
kids are having so much fun they are
becoming more independent they're more
willing to do projects on their own it's
working out great so oh that's really
good you can't do this on your own but
the thing is we all know something's
wrong so those are very practical that's
a very practical piece of advice for for
schools it's like open up the
unsupervised play
facilities and and and facilitate their
use that's right give give everyone a
place which is safe and by safe i mean
physically safe right never use the word
safety to describe emotions and ideas
safety means physical safety so you got
to provide a physically safe place for
the kids to play and beyond that you let
them go now there will arise problems of
bullying so if it's repeated harassment
or you know well i know a book about
that
it's by dan always called bullying what
we know and what we can do about it and
it was written it's got to be 30 years
ago and always cut the rule the the
the the incidence of bullying in the
scandinavian countries down by 50
percent and he really really targets
what bullying means so he's not a safe
space guy by any stretch of the
imagination um i don't know what the
origins of it are i know that
evaluations of his program in america
show anywhere from zero to twenty
percent reductions yeah well i so the
effects are much smaller in the u.s in
the us yeah the question is whether or
not they were able to implement them
with the rigor he did in the us
yeah but bullying programs are part of
the problem because bullying clearly is
a problem we need to do something about
it but because we have what's called
concept creep
yeah so so it's not imagine what concept
creep looks like even yeah that's right
uh so now it's the case that if
if kids don't invite if some kids want
to do something and they don't invite
another kid they've excluded that kid
right well that could be bullying right
i've read of schools
in europe that don't allow kids to have
best friends for exactly that reason
yeah well because
this is also something that really
bothers me about the misuse of the iat
because it's not that easy to
distinguish in-group preference which no
one can no one in their right mind would
want to eliminate in-group preference
given that it governs your choice of
mate and your behavior towards your
family members let's say
to distinguish that between out group
exclusion there's no in no simple matter
and to tell kids that they can't have a
best friend is another thing that
interferes with an important part of
their that's right yeah i think both of
us have spent a lot of time looking at
ancient wisdom at the writings of of
people long ago uh and i often come back
to aristotle's claim that any virtue
carried to extremes becomes a vice
so inclusion is a good thing if people
are being excluded because they have a
physical stigma or because or they're
overweight or their skin color so you
know we need to be looking at the
reasons why kids are excluded but if you
say inclusion is the primary virtue
inclusion over everything else
and so if those two best friends are
excluding others no more best friends
right this is madness yeah this is a
vice so i think that inclusion again you
know
it's a virtue unless it's carried two
extremes
well that's probably a pretty good place
to stop i would say unless you have do
you have anything else that you wanted
to talk about we were we talked about
the role of religion and and the fact
that people are naturally religious
thinkers we talked about the heterodox
academy we talked about your work on
disgust and your plans for the academy
you talked about your books
is there anything else that that might
be of interest that you can think of
um
just that uh i'll just say
that i'm actually optimistic about
what's going to happen on campus i think
things might continue to get worse this
year
but i think
there's an interesting phenomenon called
preference falsification
when you have
people not speaking honestly
as you had under communism
when you have a whole system where
almost everybody thinks this is terrible
i hate this but i don't dare say
anything
when you have preference falsification
it's worked by team or quran
um and everybody hears everybody else's
preferences so they think okay that's
what everybody thinks
when you have an unraveling it can
unravel very quickly and that's what
happened in the communist countries
because everybody hated it yeah um and
it fell amazingly quickly and i think
the you know the the pushback it read uh
last week or that was written last week
so i think because most people we're
starting to see is that a lot of people
of color also you say you know you're
not speaking for me i mean every group
is diverse and so
um when you have a variety of people and
you have progressives speaking when you
have a variety of people
i think we're going to see more and more
people standing up saying
wait what's happening is this is not
right this is illiberal this is opposed
to the values of the academy this is not
what i want for myself or my kids or my
students
so i do think that we're going to start
seeing a lot more people standing up
and one of our goals at head rocks
academy is to just help put out the
ideas that people need and this is what
you're doing too just put out the ideas
critique the bad ideas and put out
concepts in that you know that can
contest in this in the space of ideas
um
get good information so if people go to
hedrocksacademy.org on our research
pages we have all the information about
what do all the polls say what's the
current information about about students
attitudes we have the history of this we
have a lot of research on who is more
biased left or right well it turns out
both sides are about equally biased
so we think that by just doing what we
actually do well as academics that is
research
making arguments being calm and civil
um we actually think that we can turn
this around so if anybody watching this
is a professor i would uh invite you to
join go to hedrocks academy.org
and sign up okay so let me ask you one
more question i mean i'm that that
sounds good and i'm it's good to hear
that you're optimistic i mean i waver um
although i wouldn't say i'm pessimistic
i just think we're in one of those
situations where things could spiral in
either direction very rapidly and that
worries me
what about the disciplines on campus
that seem to be primarily devoted to the
activist cause like because my view is
or my fear is that we've subsidized
the activist disciplines let's say
women's studies as a good example but we
could say social work and then the
faculties of education now as well i
think they're in the same
in the same
bin let's let's let's put it that way
the women's studies programs in
particular their their express
goal
expressed on their websites is to
produce social justice radical
left-leaning activists and so
like for a while one of the things i
proposed in canada was that the
conservatives in particular cut the
university funding by 25 so that the
universities would have to sort
themselves out but then that was that
was a provocative claim obviously but
then i thought well that's not a good
idea because it opens up the door to
political interference in the academy
and that's bad that's conservatively
left no that's right
but the academy's done a very bad job of
policing itself methodologically and we
have these disciplines women's studies i
think is a prime example and that's been
very much criticized in canada by janice
fiamenko who used to be yeah
yeah she is and she's she she's not in
her natural miliew when she's doing such
things you know she's she's a brave and
tough person and she's gone after the
women's studies types on methodological
grounds particularly but but
there are people who are working
full-time at doing nothing but producing
the kind of polar so what do you have
any thoughts about yes i do i think
so um here i teach in the business
school here and i teach a course called
professional responsibility
and i teach my students about their
fiduciary duties
their duties to their employers the
duties that we have to each other
and fiduciary duty refers to a very very
high standard of care if you're managing
someone's money you know you you really
have to be committed to doing what's in
their interest not in your interest
and i think we need that concept in the
academy
we have i'm not sure if we call
fiduciary duties or just professional
duties but i think we have two primary
professional duties that we must never
never betray
one the most important one in our role
as scholars is our duty to the truth we
must never
say things that we think are false or
allow people to say things that we think
are false because we're afraid if we
challenge them we'll get in trouble so
we have a fiduciary due to the truth and
political ideological commitments
clearly
warp us they make us do things they make
they push us
um so we've got a whole we we've got to
recognize that if we let our systems get
out of whack we are betraying the truth
where systemically
we want to we have a systemic truthism
problem we are systematically betraying
the truth in many of our disciplines so
i think we need an awareness of that and
we need to hold ourselves to a higher
standard then in our role as teachers we
have and here we really can call it a
fiduciary duty
these are people's children who are sent
to us to educate
to enlarge their minds to teach them
skills
if we were to use them for our sexual
pleasure it's obviously a horrific crime
but what is it if we use them for our
ideological purposes if we say you've
given your children to educate i'm
waging a political battle i'm going to
try to get used to them as tools tools
that is horrific that is unacceptable we
are violating our duties so i think
right but the the the response to that
especially from the post-modernist types
is that
that's all there is there's only
ideological yeah
perfect so back to your original
question um are there problem
departments absolutely so i wanted to
put forth these two commitments to truth
and to educating not indoctrinating yeah
and
universities that embrace these highest
goals like the university of chicago i
think is the best candidate
will probably find
that they need to
do something about departments that
don't live up to those goals
other universities and i think brown is
leading the way on this one so far i
mean the
early in 2015 the president had all
kinds of statements about brown is
committed to social justice a
fundamental a bedrock commitment to
social justice she said
so if some universities choose to devote
themselves to social justice that's fine
just be upfront about it say so so
students will know if you want social
justice training you go to brown
but if you want to actually be trained
to find the truth to do research you go
to chicago
and i think we're going to see people
flooding
to chicago and schools like it so what
i'm hoping what i'm hoping so that's the
mechanism there if they if they make the
if they make their statements public
that the choice of the students will be
to go to the universities that hold the
principles that you just described over
the other ones it'll be a marketplace
choice exactly that's right so that's
why i said when i talked about the
emperor's new clothes we have a
situation we have a gigantic market
failure in which our top universities
are offering a product that most
consumers don't want
right and so my prediction is that
chicago is going to see a huge surge of
applications this year and if that's
true
um i think other universities are going
they're going to take police they're
going to take notice so i'm hoping that
we'll see a schism in the american
academy between those universities that
stand up and say this is madness we are
committed to providing a platform we
don't discriminate based on viewpoint
politics that's the chicago way and
those that say no we're about social
justice come here and we will train you
to fight for social justice and against
the right
so if if people have clear choices
then i think we're going to see
a big change and that's why i'm
optimistic because i think we're going
to see that
all right well thank you very much it
was great talking with you